the u.s doesn't have enough homes
this line shows how many months it would
take for the current supply of housing
to run out it's a measure of housing
supply and it's been dropping for a
decade
and this line shows how housing prices
have changed they've skyrocketed in the
past year for rental units the
percentage of empty buildings is the
lowest it's been in three decades while
rent prices keep going up but here's the
thing
often when new buildings go up in these
places
people
hate them it's hard to describe
but
you know it when you see it
did your vacation build up
most often they're talking about new
buildings like this boxy modern
multi-family homes i saw one one day
that sort of hit me and it was a tick
tock that was showing this building in
camden new jersey that's jerusalem dems
us a vox policy reporter
you know the comments ranged from a
bunch of different things there was
people kind of deriding the building
itself saying that it was causing
displacement saying get ready for a
starbucks to come and pop up
comments like this are a common
narrative to many these buildings don't
just look bland and artificial
they signal raised rents displacement
and the complete transformation of a
neighborhood to a place that's richer
and wider
but in this case what happened next
might surprise you i started like kind
of like going around trying to find the
specific location walking around google
maps and eventually i find it and i find
the building i look at the address i
look into private records to figure out
what this building was and not only is
it new housing it's actually new
affordable housing
turns out there's a lot we get wrong
about how we see new construction in the
u.s
whether it's dc oakland or austin
newer apartment buildings in the u.s
have a distinct look one that sticks out
against older architecture
but these buildings don't look like
historic homes for a reason this
building is actually one of the cheapest
ways to build an apartment building
right now the design is strategic
according to reporting from curb this
kind of architecture is built to fit
within restraints like cost height
limits and safety requirements it's why
many of these structures are what's
known as five over one or one plus five
that means there are several levels of
wood framed construction which usually
contain apartments and is known as type
5 in the building code that's over one
level with a concrete base which usually
contains commercial space or parking
known as type one
the light frame wood construction flat
windows and paneling around the building
are all ways to build as affordably as
possible and that means you're able to
build more affordable housing i think a
lot of the time people don't understand
that
in order to get affordable housing the
actual components of the building have
to be cheap to develop and to construct
the results can be bland and look
artificial but that authenticity problem
is an old one in this book the invention
of brownstone brooklyn suleiman osman
writes about the iconic brownstones of
brooklyn a design that today is widely
considered to be deeply authentic to new
york
but in the 19th century compared to the
mostly wooden homes that predated them
critics actually dismissed brownstones
as modern and artificial they called
them out as products of the mechanical
age poorly built and subject to decay
with a dehumanizing monotony
sound familiar
comments in a lot of those tik tok
videos they say things like oh it looks
like mass produced they look phony i
mean that's literally the exact same
language that was being used in the
1900s to talk about the brownstones
that building we mentioned earlier in
camden new jersey was built using
low-income housing tax credits it has
245 units geared towards seniors and
families making less than 60 percent of
the area's median income it's easy to
see why the construction of affordable
housing like this is a good thing but
what about the new market rate buildings
that service middle and higher income
people
they've come to symbolize displacement
or the idea that existing residents
could be forced involuntarily to move
out often for reasons like rent
increases or eviction
since developers like to build in places
where prices are already rising
new buildings tend to correlate with
those increased rents and displacement
but a growing number of researchers have
tried to find out whether these new
buildings are the cause of displacement
they were testing the demand effect or
the idea that the new buildings
increased demand for the neighborhood
which in turn caused rent hikes that
forced people to leave
but the research suggests the opposite
an overwhelming supply effect where
increasing the supply of new buildings
even if they are market rate made
housing less scarce and decreased rents
and risks of displacement especially in
the areas closest to the new buildings
new housing freed up space within a
neighborhood for new residents to move
in without taking up existing homes
and it also meant when they moved from
their past homes they freed up housing
units in those neighborhoods as well
but here's the thing less displacement
was happening near new construction but
it didn't necessarily mean less
gentrification was happening because
gentrification and displacement aren't
the same thing while displacement
happens to people gentrification happens
to a place when an area experiences
demographic change typically going from
lower income tenants to higher income
ones shown here in the darker green
over time demographic shifts in the
neighborhood could still occur not
because existing residents were
displaced but for other reasons maybe
people decided to move to more desirable
neighborhoods or some passed away
and the research suggests when that
happened residents were more likely to
be replaced by richer people meaning
gentrification was happening but without
forced displacement
so to reduce both displacement and
gentrification you need more market rate
and affordable housing like that
building in new jersey
affordable housing along with policies
like rental assistance preserve income
diversity making sure that those with
lower incomes can always live in a
particular neighborhood
if there is a scarcity of a product we
know this in every market when there is
not enough of something the only people
who get anything are rich people and so
you have to make sure that there's
enough for everyone at every level
but there's one very big obstacle to
building housing for everyone everywhere
wealthy neighborhoods across the u.s are
really good at blocking new housing
developments
take a look at this map of new haven
connecticut compared to the nearby
wealthier town of woodbridge connecticut
when we take a look at local zoning laws
and where multi-family developments are
allowed in these areas there's virtually
no land in woodbridge zoned for them
single-family zoning laws block the vast
majority of apartments or affordable
housing in this area
when you have political power
concentrated in the hands of very few
wealthy homeowners and they say we're
not going to allow housing here of
course there's going to be an unequal
distribution of housing
in 2020 after a four unit multi-family
building was proposed in woodbridge a
group of residents even created these
flyers saying do we want this next door
pitting single-family homes against
multi-family buildings
and this kind of conflict happens
everywhere from woodbridge
to soho to san francisco
in some places activists have found a
way to use the language of
gentrification against changing zoning
laws
for example in response to a proposed
california bill pushing for more housing
near areas with transit including a
specific percentage of affordable
housing
a group called livable california said
building more housing would add jet fuel
to a gentrification crisis they see the
power of this rhetoric and they are
using it as a tool to muddle the debate
to make it seem like building new
housing is actually going to create
displacement when we know what creates
displacement is not building new housing
that's what's so kind of dangerous about
this entire debate we have gotten to a
place where the actual policy solution
is seen as part of the problem
[Music]
you